you know I don't know if I really like
superhero movies anymore
I mean after doing that episode I've
become somewhat disillusioned with them
because I started seeing those same same
patterns over and over again in fairness
particularly to to Batman I don't know
if I gave Batman really a fair shake
because it's a little bit more
complicated than I made it seem I don't
think that Christopher Nolan wants us to
think of Batman as the hero and I think
that well I hope that years from now I
think we're going to be looking at it in
a completely different light where
Batman is not necessarily the hero I'm
hoping that years from now we look at
Batman is essentially a product of a
dark and desperate time it's
wish-fulfillment but I think along the
lines of you know wishes that shouldn't
be wished in the first place you know
it's one thing to think that something
like Batman is a good idea it's another
thing to try and make it into flesh and
I do think that this actually is very
serious this is a very fairly serious
social issue that we're running into
where we we have become quite willing to
trade our civil rights for security and
uh you know that's that's not just in
the realm fantasy that's not just in the
realm of movies that's something that
has happening I think whether
intentional or not our media creators
particularly those creating action
movies and superhero movies have have
bought this have bought this narrative
of of security at all costs and I think
we're fabricating a mythology where
where anything is permissible anything
is acceptable in the name of stopping
you know unnamed unspoken threats
basically terrorism we are we are making
some very very poor decisions in the
process of that and I think our cultural
narrative is is a swaging us of that
like oh no no no no you're making these
trade-offs but it's it's okay it's not a
your
not making terrible decisions we need to
believe that we're not making terrible
decisions but you know we are the the
movies that I included in the list
aren't certainly aren't the only ones
and some of them are are more egregious
offenders than others a lot of people
have written do to defend of vendors in
various forms sayings like our will
shield is actually an international
organization and technically yes in the
movie it is an international
organization but that's a pretty not
international organization for an
international organization probably the
most egregious offenders that I've seen
recently was gangster squad dear God
that was an offensive movie um well it
is very loosely based on some actual
events the the message of the movie is
not even implicitly it's like this is
not an implicit message that only it's
not subtext this is text and movie that
basically the reason why we have crime
the reason why we have gangsters and
terrorists is because the police and I
would extend this to the military the
police in the military have to follow
laws and laws are holding them back if
it worked for those pesky laws then
they'd be able to clean up all the crime
um and now this is somewhat the the
story behind gangster cloth school the
story behind Gangster Squad is rooted in
in real-life events and there was
actually a gangster squad in LA back in
the back post war in the 40s and 50s and
they did do things that would be
considered illegal these days uh but
that that nuance was completely absent
from the movie in fact they they
outright glorified the fact that oh
here's this squad and they've been given
permission to break the law in fighting
crime
and rather than looking at that rather
than treating that like a you know what
it should be which is a kind of dark
compromise um you know basically selling
selling your soul I mean there are a lot
of dark implications behind that but
rather than treating like that it was
straight-up glorified like oh hey this
is how stuff gets done because every
because of the system itself is
incompetent in the system itself is
incapable of protecting you cannot be
protected by bylaws you can only be
protected by people with unlimited power
and zero accountability who can do
everything that is necessary everything
that they deem necessary in order to in
order to get the job done and a lot of
people are kind of you know I am about
about Superman and the fact that if I
okay well who you know I'm not the only
person a lot of people have pointed this
out and it's actually one of the things
that sort of makes Lex Luthor an
interesting character is saying like
okay who gave Superman permission to uh
to rule over us effectively you know be
judge jury and executioner and a lot of
people say that like they defend that
notion by saying that that Superman
Superman can do the job because Superman
always makes the right choice and I
heard that a lot Superman always makes
the right choice and the problem I have
with that is that so far none of the
movies have actually answered the
question why I can buy that I can buy
that Superman always makes the right
choice but I want to see why Superman
always makes the right choice I want to
see that defendant um you know because
then people say okay well you know PAH
can't gave him his moral compass and
that's all well and good I mean but a
lot of people have a good moral compass
but not everybody always makes the right
choice not everyone with a good moral
compass always makes the right choice
man is not omniscient can't see the
future he can't you know see through
time and space and understand all of the
possible implications so how is it that
Superman can always make the right
choice there there is I think an answer
in that maybe that he does you know but
but there's a learning process
Superman is at the end of the day a kid
raised in Kansas yeah he was raised by
good parents but he can't see everything
he's going to make mistakes in becoming
Superman and I really wish that Man of
Steel had actually uh investigated that
a bit more you know watching Superman
become Superman not just not just
realizing his powers but growing into
that sense of morality and the worldview
where he can make ultimately the right
choice or at least the best choice
because what allows Superman to make
that right choice is the fact that he is
invincible the fact that he is basically
God among men and that he is free from
petty human concerns you know there's
there's no government that can threaten
him so that that waits that fear that
you know that pressure of all I need to
protect my own ass doesn't exist he's
free of that burden and being free of
that birdie that's what allows him to to
always take you know to think
objectively and think big picture and
think long-term and that's what allows
me to always ordinarily always make you
know the right choice or or to to find
the necessary compromises also the fact
that he has this you know vast amount of
power that he can actually you know
enable and enforce various various
solutions and and I think that that I
think that that's something that is
interesting about Superman and something
that we could investigate more in the
media about him and and unfortunately
this is kind of what makes Man of Steel
a little bit of a bad movie the script
is an absolute hot mess because what's
constantly happening they sort of tease
this idea
you're going to be watching him like
grow morally they keep doing these
flashbacks and I do like that setup you
know it's like oh they do this flashback
back to Kansas to him growing up and
they set up some kind of moral lesson
some kind of they set up some kind of
growth moment by it's like oh here's
here's an anecdote from his past and
then they flash forward but the lesson
that he just learned has no bearing on
the scene that immediately follows so
rather than it being a here's the lesson
he learned when he was a kid here's the
application of it as he's growing into
the skin of Superman doesn't happen uh
and and so that becomes a problem I like
that they sort of teased at it like they
kind of tried they were headed in the
right direction but then they just
completely fumbled fumbled the execution
of it
because you don't you don't actually see
him you know really him destroying the
city should have happened early in the
movie and we should have spent a lot
more time dealing with the consequences
of that I have no problem with Superman
accidentally destroying metropolis I
think that's actually like bloody
brilliant but what are the consequences
of that
where's Superman's moment of going oh
crap I really need to be careful um
because that's a huge mistake to make
and I actually find I find it believable
that Superman would make those kinds of
mistakes but but we need to explore the
cop like the interesting stuff is
exploring the consequences of I don't
think I should really spend a whole lot
of time talking about Superman and how
they should have done Man of Steel
differently it's not it's not terribly
relevant to the subject of Han gangster
squad
oh geez I oh man I was so so offended by
that movie and just it's
it's glorification of reckless abusive
power one way or another I think that by
consuming such a tremendous amount of
media that all focuses on this exact
same message we are we are
indoctrinating ourselves we are becoming
complicit and we are we are swayed in
our own guilt over the recklessness of
our society and that's that is not a
good thing if it's not good for us it's
not good for future generations it's not
it's not good for anyone um and so I I
think I have I think I have talked
myself out of liking superhero movies in
most action movies uh I'm hoping that
they get better again there's actually a
lot more politics present in mass media
than we often realize a lot of times
people will sort of back away and say
whoa hey you know it's just a movie um
but but here's the thing is that the
people who are making the movie they
don't well why okay they do kind of live
in bubbles but they don't you know
they're not they're not on some other
planet just quietly working away
completely oblivious to what's going on
around them they still you know are part
of society and the things that worry all
of us the economy the government the
wars the in the environment these impact
them they're still humans making it and
they still have their own agendas and
they have their own worries and they
have their own fears and they also have
you know a measure of a measure of power
and they get money by exploiting the
things that we want to see that's
something to absolutely remember they
are actively exploiting you for money
and sometimes that works out you know
fine for everybody uh everyone has fun
everyone you know learn something they
make money we get cultural fulfillment
we get catharsis but sometimes the
messages get
we really messed up and sometimes the
message that we're being sold is not a
message that we should want to hear uh
but maybe we do want to hear it because
I mean let's face it we don't always
want what's best for us this is one of
the big reasons why we need to be
critical about the media that we consume
is because the media does not have our
best interests at heart we can change
the course of the media that gets made
by voting with our wallets by choosing
to see it by choosing to consume it we
influence what gets made because they're
just going to keep selling us more of
whatever we go to see and if we continue
to buy this message of it's okay to just
to to to bathe in power fantasies where
the avatars of our nation's uh trod over
all opponents without you know without
regard for casualties without regard for
consequences without regard for due
process without regard for habeas corpus
without regard for of judicial systems
that is horrifying
that is if implications of that are
terrible and the big problem is that
while it may seem like just a small
fantasy in the media we consume
absolutely has an impact on us and if we
keep buying that message it we are going
to start believing that message if we
don't believe it already and that means
that as those who do mean us are or do
mean to wrest control from us continue
to siphon more and more power away from
us that will just kind of sit back and
go oh maybe it's not such a bad idea if
the NSA has all this power because I
mean you got to do what you got to do
maybe it's okay
the FBI doesn't need a warrant to tap
into your email or to tap into your
phone because you got to do what you got
to do and maybe it's okay if the CIA
just you know goes and destabilizes
other countries because I mean you've
got to do what you got to do in order to
keep us safe
and that's that's actually how things
fall apart and we we have been watching
a systematic and terrifying dismantling
of our rights and our safety all in the
name of safety because we're
concentrating more and more power and
hands fewer and fewer people who have
little to no accountability we're
basically trying to create superheroes
and we are thirsting for this myth of
the superhero because it tells us that
that behavior is not a bad idea you know
Superman always makes the right decision
how about an idea can it be